the messages I'm about to show you guys
are the messages that I sent to sagitt
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
this is the Quran
as you guys can see
I swear upon the lord of the Kaaba I
swear upon the one who has sent this
this GitHub if anything I'm gonna say
here is a lie a manipulation a diversion
tactic yeah
that's the oath I've taken
I won't take an oath or risk my
hairafter just to win a point over
someone else that's childish and it's
pathetic
I'm genuinely doing these videos just so
you guys can understand the full story
and the timeline of what happened
because like Ali radina on said like he
said he heard from the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him that
the message of Allah said to him Ali
that when you have two people disputing
that come to you
do not make judgment until you listen
the other side
this is a key factor many times we have
people coming to us sometimes crying
sometimes it might be a sister or a
brother
and when you see them and you hear this
story you feel for them
but sometimes when you hear the other
side
Things become a bit clear it doesn't
mean that the sister or the brother is
not hurt or not wrong of course they can
be hurt but you get a more clearer
picture and you can be just and like the
mystery of Allah peace be upon him
that that will be true Justice that is
how you apply True Justice by hearing
both sides
now once again brother Sajid released a
video and in that video even his
thumbnail and the way he's made himself
to out to be look I'll make it very
clear
with his tone
the way he conducts himself
he might seem and I'm not doubting him
but him having a certain tone on the way
he talks of a soft tone doesn't make him
right and neither does it make a person
let's say for example I'm a bit more you
know raw a bit more talkative or have a
certain demeanor neither does that make
me wrong I have never ever said that I
am not I cannot be corrected I have
refuted people publicly Adam Saleh for
the trip Dina Tokyo her husband and many
other people they liked because of the
evils that they were calling to us which
was Haram but even before we did that we
message them in private for our own
sincerity because we didn't want to be
opportunistic individuals who are like
let me find a slip of him because he's a
public figure he's got many followers
and let me go and refute him what we did
is we tried to advise them in private to
the best of our ability because this is
what should be done
but we was rejected so then we had no
choice but to go public after Consulting
with our teachers and weighing up the
good and the bad of course with our
teachers not by our own self now the
question is why
or what makes anyone think or sad you
think that I will have an issue with
being corrected
I have done this to people why would I
be an hypocrite and be like no it cannot
be done to me when have I ever ever said
that I cannot be corrected in public
when
now this is the second issue
but I want to come to with Sajid Sajid
this is not something personally has
done to me it's not a personal issue I
have nothing personal against him
he has done nothing personal against me
the point is this brothers and sisters
when I say his hate for us is greater
than his love for Islam I'm talking
about the Masada and the master meaning
that he dislikes us so much to the level
that he would jeopardize Islam looking
bad or the enemies of Islam using our
bickering against us there was a study
done by yakin Institute and they found
out that most people who leave Islam
they leave because of the bickering and
in in a in a fighting between the
Muslims that's the reason why I tried my
best to avoid this the messages I'm
about to show you guys are the messages
that I sent to Sajid these are private
messages but I'm only showing my side
and I'm not showing what he said because
it's private I'm only going to show you
guys what I said well I say this is just
a general like how my relationship with
Sajid was before I even used to refer to
him as ustad Sajid some people say to me
look it's not really and it was Dad I
just said I'll respect somebody who
studied Medina I showed him the utmost
respect we need to understand and Sajid
has not only attacked me he's attacked
SQ which he'd done a video where he was
very frustrated and even crying oh my
soul man um Muhammad hijab
um myself Jake the uh metaphysician
Abdullah andalusi yeah so it's not a
personal matter pertaining to me he has
done this many many times before to
multiple people now the question is this
is it fair brothers and sisters that he
is continuously attacking people who are
on the front line who at least have some
experience dealing with the enemies of
Islam
face to face is it fair for someone who
doesn't have that experience to come and
criticize now let's put me to a side he
did this with hijab what did hijab do
hijab did an interview with a trans
hijabi and trying to give him dawa to
make him understand why he is wrong
they do a video attacking him and I
message him and in this message you can
see very clearly I'll read it for you
guys and I said to him this can easily
be discussed and come to an agreement or
discriment but we shouldn't take it to
public as they see us all as one unit
as you can see guys my concern is what
let's not fight
I all I'm seeing is look we have this
agreement message privately message
privately we are open to advice we are
not seeing message privately because we
are infallible and don't you dare you
know we are the royal family you can
criticize us if we commit to Haram
criticize us what did I do in that
debate or discussion something cringe
that's why you have to go public so I
said in very clearly when this comes to
the issue of hijab look I'm telling him
please let's discuss it privately again
and I said to him yeah he shouldn't have
done that but we can only give Nasir but
we should speak in private with these
matters as the harm outweighs the good
the new seems a bit nitpicking on
everything I don't understand why he
does it to Mufti men to omasariman to
hijab to hijab to a hijabi fully covered
to take pictures whatever okay this was
something brother was doing okay I could
have come out and attacked them but no
yeah and then I said yeah or just let
him be because he's not causing greater
harm so I'm trying to reason with him to
not attack hijab publicly yeah the
fingers look um look I know that you may
not know it wasn't needed because the
thing is it was the issue wasn't that
major Audrey I'm trying to say it wasn't
like that deep
if it was that deep like issue I would
understand but it really wasn't that
deep and especially like with us like
it's like well I know the brother he can
contact me why is he not contacting me
if he's not contacted directly it was
like shaytan comes you know what's his
so is there a reason why he was looking
for a reason to go public is this
because of the whole year Kingdom that's
why he was saying things I said bro
don't say that because that's
accusations you know it just makes you
look bad so the thing is this is where
shaytan comes into play so with these
things it wasn't that deep you know yes
we might see a Transit job it doesn't
make hijab wrong I'm trying to say so
definitely he would have appreciated
if you spoke to him and just talk about
your concerns and maybe I heard him out
and say you know what this is where
these guys are coming from it's very
important to communicate that's that's
why as his brothers we must help him in
this private in his weakness trust me I
disagree with hijab I also have to cater
for the sake of Allah this don't mean we
tiptoe around him if we see him do major
mistakes we will straighten him but till
we see that we must help one another
nasia don't mean that Nasir don't mean
that the person must see it immediately
we gave that one that woman Nasir for
two to three years privately until he
totally lost it and I said these people
who told you to do it either like wisdom
or using you to attack hijab it wasn't
really that deep what do you think these
messages are in these messages I am
trying to tell to tell Sajid please do
not attack publicly why because the
Fatma is going to cause it makes it it's
distasteful the youth that are watching
us is distasteful for them they don't
want to see us bickering they watch both
of our content so I was trying my best
to mitigate the circumstances but no the
point I'm trying to say brothers and
sisters is that I tried my best
privately and with those audio notes
that you heard I'm trying my best to
tell him and this is pertaining to hijab
now after this I was told to be wary
about Sajid
but I didn't listen I'll give the
benefit a doubt I asked shot with man to
reconcile I said let's put things
suicide for the sake of Allah we don't
want this internal conflict let's
reconcile
share with man said something to me
which I'm not I can't really say he's in
a manner
and I was shocked I was like if it's for
the sake of Allah why do you not want to
reconcile what is stopping you from
reconciling
he outright rejected it
no problem I left it Sergeant contacts
me I left that I do not want to talk and
engage with him I genuinely believe that
he backstabbed me and many other Dua he
did I believe that I would go to
yomakayama in front of Allah with this
claim I I believe this
and then he messages me four weeks ago a
month ago like I'm his friend after as
if he has done nothing like the
entitlement like I and I'm like why are
you messaging me don't talk to me I
don't want to talk to you oh my
knowledge North wants to talk to you I
don't want to talk to you but leave me
alone he messaged me a month ago
trying to provoke me and the guy he's
even worse you mentioned not well this
is a sergeant with the soft tone nice
manners when I'm bringing evidence to
the table these tasks saying oh I do
have mental issues to me
when I asked him simple questions about
enjoying a good infinite even principles
like I've already been team here totally
ignores me no answer no answer
and I went to Fareed and this is look
Farid gave me the permission and I want
to show instead of say it because word
for word I do not want to misconstrue it
Fareed what was the agreement two weeks
ago that I will come off Twitter and I
want reconciliation for the sake of
Allah again let's just reconcile
also what's happening with Sajid
is he reluctant
um yeah I I think
the best thing is that we go on a zoom
called video core me you and him yeah
and we talk about it I have no problem
but you let me know it seems like he's a
reluctant
what does he do
Fareed comes to me and says
you guys can read it for yourself I
can't see it in front of me but
something along the lines of bro in this
one on this one I can't do nothing
is that coming from me I wanted to meet
inside it on a zoom meeting let's talk
it out let's talk let me tell you why I
believe he backstabbed us and you can
tell me why you believe you didn't let's
talk and come to a common ground and for
the sake of Allah leave it he outright
rejects reconciliation and then says
what he did was for the sake of Allah if
it's for the sake of Allah for Islam to
flourish yeah why would you not want
reconciliation this is a question that
needs to be asked it's very very clear
guys
very very clear and I hope he doesn't
have a God for read for this
and starts having an issue with him
because of
me showing these messages you guys can
see from my messages guys and the
audience that I I played yeah but I
wanted nothing but to dive avert to stop
this fitna from going public I have
tried my best with hijab and when I saw
him doing the same with me and then
Abdullah and Lucy then I'm so sorry
he is a cereal I'm so sorry he seems
like a cereal backstepper I will only
apologize for the people who have come
to witness this
it's as simple as that brothers and
sisters I come from a revert I'm I'm a
revert okay I couldn't I came to Islam
my family is very very hostile to Islam
a lot of my family members are actually
enemies of Islam yeah they outright in
salt Allah this messenger yeah so the
thing is when I first came to Islam the
Brotherhood was something that also
caught my attention yes you need to
understand when I am dealing with
enemies of Islam outside or we are only
person I'm talking about myself
we already deal with in our houses okay
well our house is like family Etc I
already deal with it a reverse life is
not really that good okay because you're
dealing with this hearing in the house
you go and do that you hear it from
there you go speaker screen and you hear
people insulting the mystery of Allah do
you know how much control it requires
for us to
you know hold ourselves back when that
is happening
and then we have people that we see as
brothers
um and many other people that we see are
dear to us as brothers that we trust and
we turn to the point is this Sajid was
another person that I genuinely
genuinely saw him as that if Fareed on a
video just like what Sajid done I would
have been as hurt or Mansoor or Ham's
resources whoever that may be the reason
these brothers all came to me in private
and not public shows us something one of
these well shall I say either Sajid or
10 plus members who advised me privately
like hikmah I'm gonna go with
not these brothers because they could
have gone and do that in public
scientists are claiming that these
people are scared of me I asked Fareed
that very question I said bro
why did you not refute me in public are
you scared of me and he sent a Emoji
laughing and I don't blame him it is a
laughing matter the reason these
brothers didn't come publicly is number
one I didn't
there was no Shabba Hut number one
thrown out there like
um that I couldn't answer
and I didn't do and all I did was
something cringe okay we are dealing
with an enemy of Islam
and brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second put yourself in my shoe you
have a friend that you talk to you're
calm like you talk to you for your your
brother what they say blood is thicker
than water we say Iman is thicker than
blood brothers and sisters you have a
Muslim brother that you talk to he knows
you he has your number you get into some
kind of a dispute with the enemy of
Islam
he not only come
and attacks you
yeah let's suppose you did something
wrong but it was generally for the sake
of Allah you anger towards the enemy of
Islam that you did something let's
suppose it was a mistake not only that
guys
they defend this guy who rips the Quran
eats the Quran who laughs at the death
of pilgrims
they defend this honor and say that Ali
dawa accused this man apos of
um indirectly inciting violence against
Muslims can you imagine you're in the
front line fighting with enemies of
Islam just imagine a war zone you're
fighting and there are arrows in front
and you're looking back and thinking
which enemy through that was it like who
what the enemy of Islam and then you
realize the arrows that are being thrown
are being thrown from your own camp
this is the point I'm trying to make
guys
anybody in my shoes would feel betrayed
and feel like they've been backstabbed
because I trusted these individuals I
gave them my number I am open to in the
seal
but instead of doing that he spends no
time wasting the tool and does a video
the very next day this is reason why
brothers and sisters I don't want any
other dwarfs getting attacked a bill and
Lucy was in the front line in the TV
station with two free people who are
trying to grill him and one guy insults
in him
and Sajid
does a video attacking him
oh why did you not condemn it why does
he have to condemn it
now since that's out the way what I want
to do is as you guys know the accusation
is very simple that I myself alidawa
have an issue with being publicly
corrected
so just put this in the context so what
that means is but I myself believe that
nobody can correct me I have no mistakes
I have no flaws I have no sins that I am
the perfect being I am the greatest die
or whatever you want to call me out
there and nobody can correct me
please I request anybody to find a
single statement or a single way I have
ever conducted myself that I have said
you are not allowed to criticize me
those who normally know me I'm gonna go
to now evantemia and we're gonna learn
from eventamia when it comes to enjoying
a good and forbidden evil what are the
things that is required in order for it
to be executed properly because talks
about this one thing that I was really
surprised is that Sajid is somebody who
studied at Medina University
and when I asked him about this I asked
him about the conditions of enjoying
another favorite and evil he didn't want
to answer rather he would go down the
roads um of actually
questioning my psychological well-being
mental well-being I mean he did this
with hijab as well that my psychological
well-being was in question when I would
ask simple questions when I would bring
evidence to certain matters that he
criticized me or for some reason he
would always avoid it and always
criticize me that for some reason I
don't know and he knows so let's go to
Evan Tamia let's see what even teamer
says that we should have the what
conditions we should have when it comes
to enjoying good and forbidden evil so
then we can have a clearer picture that
does the condition that everyone that
does something public in in the public
scene does that mean they need to be
refuted in public so everything says let
your enjoyment could be good and let
your forbidden of bad be bad
he said the truth is sometimes heavy for
some people to accept
don't make it harder with your bad Adam
if I am gonna go and stop somebody from
drinking alcohol if I see somebody
drinking alcohol if I know me going
there that that individual will take a
knife and try to stab me or a few other
people it is best that you don't do that
action because the harms outweigh the
good so the action that you're going to
do in joining good and forbidden the
evil will become impermissible for you
and here's what Ben Tamia says in
joining right and forbidden wrong being
one of the greatest obligations or
commendable acts in Islam it is
essential that the benefits they're in
at the way is negative consequences this
is the general Spirit of the messages of
the prophets and the revealed books and
Allah does not like chaos and Corruption
thus whenever the adverse affects the
math setup of any of the enjoining or
forbidding are greater than his benefits
it is no longer part of what Allah has
enjoined upon us even if it be a case of
neglecting obligations or committing the
big
even if it is a case of neglecting
obligations or committing The Forbidden
this is because it is upon the believer
to fear Allah in relation to his slaves
and the guidance is not his
responsibility this is part of the
meaning of the verse which Allah says
all you who believe yourselves you are
your responsibility those who go
straight will not harm you when you
stick to guidance now the second group
desires to enjoin and forbid the people
with their tongues and their hands
absolutely absolutely and all situation
without sufficient knowledge of the
Sharia no forbearance no patience no
regard for that which is beneficial and
that which has more harm than benefit
and that which is possible and that what
that and that which is not possible then
he goes on to say this group then
enjoins amphibious believing that they
are they are in obedience to Allah when
we in reality they are the
transgressives of his boundaries in this
way many of the deviants and misguided
groups consider themselves to be in
joiners of right and forbidities of
wrong such as
and others that and others of who of
those who Earth and understand Aid in
understanding that which Allah gave them
in terms of in joining right and
forbidden wrong and fighting Jihad and
other issues the corruption caused by
this kind of enjoying and forbidding is
much greater than any good that which
may result now we'll end on this note
somebody came and approached sages and I
saw this video of a Christian
and Sajid decides to just ignore him and
walk away
and I don't blame him he doesn't have
experience on face-to-face Tower it's
not blame worthy he has a
confrontational that's fine and
understandable nobody can blame you for
that it's understandable your Tower
style is different but the fact that you
don't have the experience and that
Christian when he approaches you you
just totally I would have gain a dino
with him I would gonna die look with him
you know because we are in the front
lines fighting these enemies Islam
intellectually
and then you have no experience not
blameworthy but you come and attacked
what Left Right Center SQ
uh Jake hijab me Abdullah and Lucy
what is your problem what do you want
from us and you know what's really funny
I saw shamshi's video recently that was
done back then and I watched it and One
Lie I was shocked shamsi at least
started the video which you guys can see
for yourself since this video
it's about
the debate that occurred between
uh this evil disrespectful liar
a a prostate a liar
guiding
while referring to me as the as his
brother he's our brother even though he
believed that it was embarrassing what I
did no problem but at least he started
with Ali's our brother okay and then he
starts insulting aprils I was like come
to that at least you have Justice that
you insult this filthy scum and at least
she called me a brother I was like wow
like it meant so much to me and me and
shamsi have an issue going back two or
three years which again it pertains to
him attacking other people the same
thing with Tower man I have no personal
problem with these people and it is a
misinformation I'm not gonna say he lied
Sajid it's misinforming that I have an
issue with being publicly corrected this
is a big big
misinformation I'm not going to say it's
a lie because I don't believe he's a
liar yeah it's misinformation I have
never said that I am open to correction
from sincere people
but to go and defend apus and then write
a letter to David wood Sajid and
knowledge North and refer to David Woods
as Dr David wood and then the same
people call me imbecile and insult me
when Allah says in the Quran be soft
towards the Believers and hearts towards
disbelievers
this is the reason why it hurt me so
much because I did not expect that from
Sergeant because he had my number he
could have contact me
and that's all I have to say guys and I
apologize for those who witnessed this
but just so you guys know I did not want
this to happen brother sisters that's
all I have to say inshallah I hope this
is cleared the matter for once and
foreign inshallah
um and we ask Allah to guide him and
guide myself inshallah and be allow us
to be amongst those who are soft towards
Believers and harsh towards the enemies
of Islam rather than vice versa
islamnet is raising funds to establish a
Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Sada khajari for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and the shall American award click
the link and donate what you can